Thank Alessandro again can be a finish
off the subpoena who will be led by
ethan Zuckerman from just around the
corner I leave it to ihsan to introduce
the panelists and I will try to leave it
to him to manage the time even though I
may be sitting in the background and
watching
i'm ethan Zuckerman with the Center for
civic media just down the road at MIT
I'm lucky on the interest side of this
in that I don't have to introduce two of
my panelists because they've just
introduced themselves and their work
rather brilliantly but I'll introduce
Chris Conley immediately to my right who
is a fellow at the Northern California
ACLU where he's focused on a wide range
of issues that include privacy and
surveillance and we've worked together
previously at the Berkman Center for
Internet Society on many of these issues
I'm very grateful for the chance to sort
of bring these three folks together to
talk about privacy because we're at a
very interesting moment in time as we've
just been talking about in a world of
big data whether we're enthusiastic
about it or skeptical about it in a
world of social media there's an
enormous number of issues that come to
the fore around privacy and if you sit
down and ask people their preferences on
privacy you'll often get a very
different answer than what comes out in
their behavior because if you look at
people's behavior people seem incredibly
willing to put data out there not just
for friends but also for advertisers for
marketers and as was just pointed out
for researchers the flip side to this of
course is that when you explain to
people where that data is going what the
implications are people will sometimes
get very scared my work in this space
tends to center around the world
participatory media and particularly
issues of freedom of speech and human
rights and the story that pretty much
has my community in crisis the last
couple of weeks is an utterly harrowing
story from Nuevo Laredo where people
have been using participatory media to
sort of document the movements of drug
cartels and drug cartels have recently
decided to announce that they are well
aware that people may be anonymous they
think but are using social media to
document cartel movements and they
announce this by hanging the bodies of
three social media user
from a prominent bridge in the center of
town so these issues are not purely
theoretical for some people in the world
they are quite literally life or death
but we have three people here who've
done incredibly deep and thoughtful work
on privacy and and because we have a
very limited amount of time first I'm
going to shut up and let them talk
instead and second I'm going to ask if
everyone would sort of respond to the
question of with all that we've thought
about with all that we know about
privacy what's the really big thing that
we generally fail to talk about or fail
to address when we think about the
subject I'm gonna start with you sure um
so they're just mean so yes my name is
Chris Conley again I'm a fellow with the
ACLU in Northern California I'm an
attorney I'm also a technologist I have
been on both sides of mass ave so glad
to be back here for a while I mean the
the hardest question with privacy is not
so much what is it we could talk about
that for hours on end but the question
is what do we do about it we have all
these forces in society that are really
pushing against personal privacy from
the market forces for monetizing data to
the real challenges is pointed out
earlier about how do we handle informing
people about these distant indirect
effects of information that are very
hard to realize my favorite story from a
couple weeks ago which is a little more
pleasant than ethan's was people have
learned that you can determine people's
television habits through smart meters
sort meters are sensitive enough to
black pixels on a screen that if you
aggregate the information you can get a
fingerprint of a show and you can tell
what they're watching this kind of
information is you know something they
typical consumer wouldn't even occur to
them and there's so many pressures that
make it challenging so my job and my
challenge is how do we actually enact
change so that we can improve privacy
give people greater control with the
technology that we're seeing emerge the
way I like to frame it is a taking Lord
Lessig there are four different ways
that you can impact social change one is
law you can think about how do you
regulate this how do you put legal
protections put legal mandates have
liability that can pressure actors into
changing there are some challenges with
that
and I'll get to those at the end of this
but that's certainly one out there may
be a less obvious one is technology
technology directly impacts this kind of
thing we had an example from an earlier
talk that you can imagine technology use
to tag content with metadata to retain a
record of where this content came from
and to go back and check for permissions
check for access controls around this
content if it's been revoked if someone
has said hey I don't like that picture
from you know when I was 18 and kind of
a little bit foolish can you please take
that down respect that technology can be
built to do that of course technology
can also be built around you know to
make probably see more difficult when
you have smart meters that collect
information that is much more sensitive
than is apparent technology can really
erode privacy you have market forces and
again market forces can play both ways
you have the forces to monetize
information but you also have companies
that react to pressure on privacy you
have Google+ come out and Facebook
coincidentally come out about a month
later with a bunch of privacy changes
that strangely resemble what Google had
done a month earlier don't you know some
of that probably was coincidence they
don't change quite on a dime but there's
no doubt that companies react to
perceptions of privacy and then the
fourth one and kind of the fundamental
for us is norms you have social
movements user understandings about
privacy expectations and these are not
orthogonal these are not independent
things the key for us is how do you
interact with these how do you cause
them to pressure each other to
comprehensively create change norms for
example are strongly determined by
technology by defaults if you have a
service like Twitter where everything is
public by default and people know that
going in there's an expectation of your
publicity if you have a service like
Facebook originally where things were
very closely confined and then is
shifted into a more public mode there's
a strong outcry because people have
adapted the norm of this technology
works this way and I understand it or I
think I understand it and therefore I'm
going to react to that a technology also
affects norms by actually making people
understand what happens can you build
tools that show people how their day is
being collected can you build on you
know analysis and research that shows
people what can be inferred from data so
they have a better idea of what the
constraints are and you know there are
many many other things you know
markets drive norms norms drive market
so consumers want something and one
company isn't giving to them the
competitor will so the goal for me
really is to find ways that we can use a
multidisciplinary approach to address
privacy problems and concerns that we
have and obviously from the ACLU we have
specific concerns but there are many
different factors here the CAF to come
into play and they have to be thought
about together it's not enough to focus
on the law it's not enough to focus on
technology you have to think how do
companies impact all of these different
sectors you know and so a lot of my work
is actually oddly for an ACLU attorney I
spent a lot of time working with
companies I'm based in Northern
California so Microsoft isn't right in
my backyard but lots of others are and
talking to them about you know what are
your defaults are you designing to give
people more transparency and more
control so they have more ownership and
ability to regulate their own
information and you work with them on
legal issues because of course having
companies and nonprofit agencies and
consumers who all are informed and
active on an issue creates legal change
so I want to end by saying there are two
birthdays that I'm thinking about right
now that kind of relate to this the
first one is microsoft research of
course 20 years of very
multidisciplinary approaches to
addressing problems and this panel is
kind of out once one problem or one
issue privacy where it really takes
technologists it takes lawyers at least
sometimes it takes business people it
takes people who are really interacting
with social science and the community
and users so that they can understand
what the issues are and so all these
different forces can work together to
drive change the second birthday is not
quite so pleasant so in about a month
october 25th will be the 25th birthday
of the Electronic Communications Privacy
Act in the United States needless to say
when black bow is written in 1986 the
world has was a little bit different
webmail was or there wasn't a webmail
there was email but it was a
client-server model and so the current
law on the books in the United States
says if you have left mail on a server
for more than six months your privacy
expectation has changed because you must
have abandoned it because in 1986 that's
how it worked and the issue we have is
that this law hasn't changed because it
doesn't spontaneously change and so my
mission and my goal is to really find
the ways to use working with companies
Microsoft as part of a coalition called
digital due process as are we
working with consumers to educate them
about issues finding ways that
technology can be used to make things
more transparent so that there's all
these tools that we can put together to
really force change and see you know
craft an environment where privacy can
be respected where people can actually
control their own personal information
and so we can really go forward in a way
that we don't have to have only our
choices are we live a totally
transparent life or we go off the grid
and that just delays the inevitable
finding so that's really my big question
is how do we do that and still something
we're working on and I'm really excited
to see all the people who are working on
it here and elsewhere finding ways to
really adapt different disciplines and
different tools to make change so Chris
you and I have both had the pleasure of
working with our friends at the Berkman
Center Harvard Law School two stops that
way one of the things that I think we
both got none of that experience is a
sense that when it comes to technology
of the sort of for regulatory forces
that you mentioned that Larry Lessig is
documented law is really really slow and
and also has the tendency to sort of
hang around even when it isn't
necessarily all that directly helpful
much as you referencing women 1986 law
do you think given the fact that there
are market forces technological forces
normative forces that all seem to be
pointing towards more exposure of data a
really changing attitude of privacy do
you think we're heading for some sort of
legal collision when sort of law catches
up and tries to deal with this or you
sort of hopeful that the sorts of
initiatives that you're engaged in right
now are going to find out find some way
to sort of head this off of the past
before we hit a point of confrontation
well I'm obligated to be hopeful that
what i'm working on will be successful
quickly but um no I think I think
they're there is a challenge that you
know in many cases laws have been
written and they've really been based
around understanding of technology as it
was that this echo is a very good
example but they're they're legion and
of course you have even more issues when
you deal with international you issues
where different countries have different
rules and of course different respect
for those rules in terms of protecting
information and privacy and things of
that sort I think one of the things
that i do see and that i'm optimistic
about is that law can be used to not
just as an independent you know club to
force change or to regulate directly but
where la can increase transparency it
can prolong you know one of the issues
we have constantly is you know issues of
we are fairly confident that you know
companies get lots and lots of requests
for information about their users but we
don't know how many because there is no
record of that that's required to be
published and it would be great if there
were a law that simply said you know the
Department of Justice has to report has
to produce a wiretap report every year
that says we have issued you know 2,000
wiretaps in 2010 and there's actually a
section of that report for computer
wiretaps there were seven in 2010 and
the reason there were seven is you don't
need to tap a computer to intercept a
live communication when you could just
go to an end point and demand it without
needing a search warrant without needing
a wiretap order the more transparency we
have the more information there is have
a public dialogue about this the more
all these different pieces can really
work together and law is one way and
maybe in some cases a necessary way to
really enable a public dialogue about
this because the information may not
come out because the market pressure
there may be that makes me just you know
the nudge that is needed to really allow
all these other pieces to work but I
think they have to be part of it it
can't be just the law dictates and
everything one's happily ever after
after that so I'm not that much of a
lawyer so okay you're a provocateur as
we just saw before okay writer musician
you're also a very talented researcher
an ethnographer and I know that you've
been trying to figure out some questions
of privacy from a very different
perspective in Gujarat yes so I wanted
to ask you sort of based on that
experience of talking about questions of
privacy in a very different setting than
the setting that I think most of us are
used to think about what were the
biggest sort of surprises one of the
biggest messages we should take away
from your experience there as we think
through these questions
privacy that's a big question I think I
think for me the the really killer
question was thinking about how privacy
is incredibly culturally sensitive and
it really depends on where you are in
the world and who you are in terms of
what you think privacy is and how it
should be experienced so I was doing
have been doing a project for over 18
months now which is based in Gujarat and
specifically around villages which are
around the great run which is a big
desert between India and Pakistan and
we've been spending time in the villages
there with two other anthropologists
Cathy kitna who's at Intel and Joe taki
who's at RMIT in Melbourne and we've
basically been working with women who
are living below the poverty line in
effectively very poor villages to see
how they're using mobile phones or cell
phones and I guess the first thing that
was really interesting is that if you're
living in a single room dwelling with
six or seven other people and there is
no divided space then your idea of
privacy is very different and your
ability to have a private conversation
is very seriously constrained so I think
about the I think about the Latin root
of the term privacy which comes from the
idea of probe artists to separate to
keep things apart you can't separate and
keep things apart if you're living in a
single room dwelling with you six or
seven other people what was really
interesting was to see how these women
were using mobile phones and these are
always very basic you know often first
generation nokia phones and these are
women who were not in many cases
literate but they'd use the phone in
very basic ways sometimes with their own
systems of symbols sort of hack how they
were using the phones they would come up
with the greed messages that you know
hash star hash all mean this but was
really remarkable with the story as they
would tell me about just taking voice
calls which might seem like a fairly
everyday thing to us but for these women
they were saying that it was the first
time that they could have a private
conversation where at least half of the
conversation wasn't being overheard and
maybe at least not everybody in the
village knew who they were talking to
and this might sound like a trivial
thing but for some of these women it was
incredibly important they could speak to
their family of origin often you'll be
living with the family that married into
you and they couldn't talk to their
family about how they were feeling or if
things are going on they were worried
about if they're afraid of things they
had no way to make those sorts of
contacts so to have privacy for them was
extraordinary they told me stories about
the mobile phone being like food because
it was so important to their sense of
sustenance I mean these were really
really moving stories so in some ways I
think it's it's really changed some of
the dynamics around gender & privacy in
these kinds of villages the other thing
that's interesting too is to think about
the politics of mobility it's not just
about sort of mobile phones it's also
about where you can move in space so in
many of these villages women can't
really leave the home after dark so if
it's nighttime you have to be indoors so
the mobile phone allows you to continue
social relationships and in some cases
you know to run your business after
hours which was incredibly empowering
for some of these women's so in those
ways I think mobility has to be
understood both in terms of a technology
but also in terms of how you deal with
space so I guess I think in some ways
these sort of nuanced understandings of
what privacy means culturally often get
overlooked but it's it's often quite
different when we move outside of a very
sort of privileged Western context but I
don't want to sound like somebody who is
you know just singing the praises of
technology because actually mobile
phones are still operating within very
traditional social hierarchies right so
we might see in many cases that it's the
male head of a household who still
controls who gets to use the phone and
for how long and how much will be spent
on the phone and in other cases the most
sort of should we say sort of focused
upon population the population of
greatest concern is still young women so
if you're a young and unmarried woman
your use of the mobile phone was seen as
being quite dangerous or you know quite
disruptive so young women were really
being observed in these villages and in
many cases they just weren't allowed to
use mobiles cuz he knows they could be
talking to people that might not be
appropriate or they might be forming
relationships that weren't improved so
there there are still some very
traditional dynamics there that the
technology is still working within but I
think over time we're going to see some
really interesting dynamics emerge for
people who end up doing ethnography of
Technology there's sort of this
narrative
here's this technology we thought it
worked one way because we introduced it
into the developed world it maybe have
taken on sort of one or two or three
different uses but then it moves into
the developing world and it takes on
just radically different use that that
we hadn't even thought about at the same
time with some of the spaces that we're
sort of thinking about and talking about
here social networking spaces to a
certain extent it's all the same space
and so having a radically different
behavior pattern with gujarati women
ends up literally in the same shared
space with American teenagers do you see
any sort of collision starting to happen
as we see things like social media
platforms that are used both in India
and and the US or and Australia sort of
bringing together people who probably
don't think of themselves as using the
same space well I think it's a really
interesting question I think in some
ways it's too early to tell so with the
populations that we were working with
they don't have social media they've
never seen the internet they have no
sense of what that might be so computers
are really not part of village life in
some cases there might be a computer but
the mobile phone has radically Oh taken
the computer and the internet in these
sorts of communities so we're still
waiting to see what will happen when we
statice the emergence of phones that
give them access to the Internet in the
same way because at the moment it's
still very first gen but working with
populations in big cities in India you
see something very different obviously
the big cities are very similar to
Sydney or to Boston in terms of the way
that young people are using social media
but there's always a twist there's
always a cultural twist so one that I
found fascinating was were having a
discussion with a young man who was
talking about how I used facebook and
like many young men he uses Facebook for
dating it's like let's see who the cute
chicks are and what they might be up to
but in his case he was always checking
to see what caste women were so cast was
actually the first question around
whether or not this woman might be
somebody who would be suitable to go on
dates with so this is not something that
we use as a setting necessarily in
facebook but he was and you can so
what's really interesting is going to
see how
companies are actually tweaking their
interfaces to try and represent
particular kinds of cultural
sensitivities but also to see how
they're being tweaked back how they're
actually being changed and this is what
I think is really interesting about
mobile technology there's this great
term called dugard which means making do
and it means that you know you just open
things up you hack them you change them
you make them work to suit the
conditions and that idea of you know
that the uses for things are sometimes
not what they were designed for but the
street will have its own uses was so
evident and so present in India to see
these kinds of new packs in new ways of
using technology was really inspiring
alessandra I I know that we're we're
sort of preaching to the choir here
right because your work for many years
at CMU and your work on privacy and
behavioral economics and these are all
questions that I know that not only have
you written and thought about but you've
also sort of carried out experiments
about and have really helped put some of
the dismal into the dismal science of
economics this week as we start finding
out what people really do and really
think about it in the privacy space out
of all that work much of which has been
extremely surprising what are what are
the big surprises that you feel that it
that a group like this needs to be
thinking about in the context of privacy
one of the big topics so big that I I
don't even feel yet comfortable working
on or at least publishing about but
because we are in small group of friends
and we are not being filmed at all then
I can talk about is what I really the
cost of privacy how do we define them
sometimes I wonder the economics of
privacy has been along for quite a while
the first writings in this area date
back to the late 1970s early 1980s
Chicago School scholar pioneers like
Posner Stigler we're already writing the
time but over the years this area is
really exploded after more or less two
thousand and sometimes I wonder much of
good has come out from this explosion
economics of privacy but the wonder
whether we have inadvertently created a
frame of mind where
if you cannot prove or show a
quantifiable economic dollar damage then
there is no problem there is no cost to
privacy whatsoever so the struggle I
face within myself we're in my economics
art and then my behavior economics at is
I feel that the need for privacy is so
universal so I spread and in a way the
studies the beautiful study Kate will
refer it was referring to also testify
to that if a theorem enemy of a study by
Murphy Anna tog refer who also went to
Java in Bali trying to see how how
people enjoying body back in the 1950s
conceptualize and acted or no privacy
concerns have found that the absence of
architectural barriers between people
created stiffer social etiquette so the
people were less likely to ask personal
questions unless a very strong and long
bond existed so the point being if
privacy is so widespread in for prices
all right spread there must be some
clear obvious benefit so can we we feel
the mainstream economics course prove
that there is this benefit and prove
that there are costs when privacy
invaded or do we need to resort to the
concept of anonymity of the
psychological costs are the pure ended
economic costs so this is what would
this is one of the big questions that I
don't feel comfortable yet studying but
I keep thinking about let me push on
that a little bit right because the
danger is that economics may not be the
frame to think about this that putting a
price on the value of privacy is very
very difficult to think in in the
context of Gujarat where we're clearly
you have women's lives changed where
they get this sort of incremental
increase in privacy and I suspect we
could go and do regression studies and
try to figure out whether it's the phone
that makes them more productive and the
ability to communicate or whether
somewhere in there we can find a quality
of life improvement that's sort of
directly connected to privacy but it it
does seem a little
like you know trying to trying to pin
down jello what you you care about this
space you think an enormous amount about
it when you think about privacy and the
value of it do you think of it in legal
terms do you think of in cultural terms
do you think of in personal terms when
you try to frame the importance of these
questions for the people that you're
working with what what is it that that
you how is it that you frame that
question I mailee and these may be
controversial but I i I'm not trying
intentionally to be I mainly think about
that the test of control and by control
I am in the following there is in the
literature and the scholarly literature
privacy there are pages in pages about
privacy in control by usually the focus
is private control of a personal
information as a means to achieve
privacy okay we I find that normal in a
normative search that makes sense we
want people to have control the personal
data but it's a necessary nor sufficient
condition for privacy in fact some of
our own experiments show that if you go
from an automatic statement how the
world should be to a positive statement
how the world early is the more you make
people feel in control their data the
more risk they're going to take with
their data it's a phenomenon analogous
to us people to wear seatbelt and wear
helmets they start driving faster or
riding faster so we find that impulsive
there are certain enormity terms more
control paradoxically can create less
privacy so the important issue here to
me of control is inverting the question
and thinking in terms of how in for
knowing person information about the
person is a way to potentially control
the person so this is to me the angle
which I'm not sure I can literally
described in economic terms without
resorting to the usual example of price
discrimination if I know what your
consumer type is then I can charge you
more or less and extract more surplus
away from you but there is more not more
than that multi lavatory so we've got at
least two solutions on on the table here
for sort of how we start thinking
through privacy in sort of instrumental
terms
people who think about this as
researchers or designers or so on and so
forth week we have from Chris sort of a
call for transparency here and
essentially using the law to make
systems more transparent so we can have
better discussions event this from
Alessandra we have this really neat sort
of inversion of the paradigm of control
instead of saying the fact that we have
control over our information isn't
necessarily the right way to think about
this because we all know that more
control manage gets take more risk it's
really having the ability to control
through someone else's information that
is potentially where we want to take a
risk on sue sue sue Kate give us a give
us a solution here is a give us a tool
for our toolbox as we start to think
this through well interesting
ethnographers don't like to think that
they're in the business of giving
solutions but we love the idea of tools
and tool boxes so I can work with that I
think when we start conceptualizing the
breadth of issues that might be covered
in this term privacy one of the things
that I think is really interesting is
not just thinking about cultures but
also thinking about time so we haven't
talked about the frame of a long time
around privacy that it's not just such
as now it's not just a couple of years
hands but it's the long delay in terms
of what's going to happen to our
information and I think about that
across cultures that we're generating
all of these traces all of these paths
regardless of who we are and where we
are that are actually being collated in
used in ways that none of us right now
really know and there's no in this room
who has a full sense of how the data is
being used let alone what might be
happening to that data in future so I
think one of the things going forward
that need to think about in terms of
solutions is addressing this issue of
time and privacy and that means from a
systems level allowing people to
actually have very granular control
about exactly what is going to use and
by whom but also thinking about for how
long so the idea of you know that the
right for information to die the right
for things to disappear is actually a
significant discussion that's now
happening in Europe and I think it's one
of the discussions that we could all
benefit from participating in to think
about how do we think about the end of
information how do we think about
protecting the life cycles of data so
that's something that I'd throw in at
least as a tool if not a complete
solution
it's sort of information as a temporary
tattoo rather than as I actually made it
good luck you don't attach your sort of
hoping that your facebook status might
you know gently fade in color you know
over a course of a couple of days rather
than you know that then remaining on
your arm for four years and years to
come or rather than being connected to
my spotify account where everybody on
facebook will know every single album
that i'm listening to for the next 20
years which is a horrifying thought my
just gentle push back on that I I got
sent a wonderful link today which was
that someone has scraped all of geo
cities before yahoo shut it down and
created an 850 gigabyte torrent and put
it online has put together this
wonderful sort of visualization of this
and and as it happens geocities was the
main competitor to my company tripod and
trounced us and we totally destroyed us
though tripod still remains and still
has the sort of online presence but
they're they're both ghost towns and
they're both sort of missing in the
internet archive and I'm sort of
wondering you know whether this fear
that everything stays on record forever
actually stands up to that long time
test there's actually you know really
good evidence of sort of bit decay it's
actually very very hard to find evidence
of what we were doing online ten years
ago five years ago if you can borrow
seeing and I gotta tell you most of my
designs from the late nineteen
ninety-eight berra singh but also pretty
hard to find do you think that's true do
you think that that this sort of
personal information somehow has a much
longer life span than in some ways we've
actually seen at a digital data as yes
that's absolutely fair pointed in fact
there's been 0 this discussion on how
one of the longest most durable tools
for communication our books and not
floppy disk right however for me going
back again to my background for my angle
or behavior economies the day show time
is so crucial because and I've been
discussing this over and over but I
still like the topic so much the problem
of immediate gratification we should
related to hyperbolic discounting how
human being discount future events
future expected costs and benefits it
turns out that we human beings suffer
from immediate gratification we tend to
gratify our media self pushing the cost
of our future self by enlarge this is
true in many field including privacy
that means that even if we have a very
significant danger in our future we tend
not to pay that much attention to that
that even happens when a danger is that
is deaf studies by my colleague George
Loewenstein at CMU show that there are
certain medicines that patients need to
take regularly if they do not take them
regularly they become actually
particularly dangerous and they can
increase your risk of death later on in
the long run not the next morning and so
what lotteries wear your regular taking
of the pill arm is the price with money
are much more successful than the fear
of death if you don't take the pill
regularly so people are more motivated
by a little notary of two dollars than
the risk of dying ten years later if
that happens we have serious with the
risk of death how can we think about
protecting our privacy 10 years from now
so even Chris that that sounds like sort
of an incredible channel and try them in
because the the work that you're doing
is not just with the legal system and
not just with corporations it's really
helping individuals so to figure out how
do they advocate for their own rights
how do they advocate for privacy within
these systems that we're building
alessandra seems to be making a pretty
convincing case that that people for the
most part don't do this how do we how do
we get sort of an end user into this
discussion how does a ACLU thanks to
your questions like that I mean much of
it really is just again it's the
educating a user about technology
requires technology it's a starting
point if you can use a tool to give
someone visualizations there have been
wonderful visualisations about the
evolution of facebook privacy or you
know graphic stories of project data
from MIT
where you can take social networking
connections and determine people's
sexual orientation resonate with people
but how do you they don't accompli
accomplish some of the you know I have
an immediate threat and I will respond
to it dealing with the long term you
know time discount is I don't know I
don't have a solution to that yet I I do
think that you're one of the things that
we're we are seeing is that we have
these different I mean there are lots of
different ways to conceptualizing
privacy and harms and such but one of
the things we think about is you have
kind of four different points where
privacy kimbley implicate it and there's
collection of information retention of
information use of information and
disclosure of information and these all
have different aspects and one of the
ones that I'm most curious to see play
out although I don't know how it's going
to work is the collection side because
we're reaching a point where the public
is aware that information is being
collected and I'll be fascinated to see
if people's behavior really starts to
change when they see more stories when
they see more you know maybe again may
not be the long-term because they don't
have the perception of that you know you
have mom and dad saying that your
teenagers don't post that bad picture
and of course the teenager goes and says
okay I can set my privacy control so you
can't see it all set but i think really
we're going to see where you know these
different pieces but retention and
collection really are going to be
important here because it's not just how
the information can be used and be
harmful in the future it's about how
does the perception of it being
collected actually change behavior and
how can we help people understand and
not in a way that means you'll get
scared off you know but hopefully it's a
way that you you understand the trade
off and you say okay I want to know that
my information we protected if I'm going
to even share in the first place you
know I'm going to adjust my facebook use
if you're going to change your policies
different ways where we can really use
different people's perceptions but it's
not you know the time delay is probably
the hardest way sure you could have
asked me because that's something that
is a really tough thing for any user
anyone in this room to understand what's
going to happen in you know ten years
where smart grids and GPS and this
aggregate disparate information that all
seems fairly innocuous in and of itself
but you put it together and the
consequences are beyond what people can
understand how do you have going back
someone else's do you have a retroactive
solution for the data that you didn't
even know was being collected five years
ago by a third party who you don't even
know you know they've been bought out by
three other companies since then I don't
know
and it it sounds like before any of us
actually know this we may need sort of
the global experience of being caught on
Facebook drinking an underage beer it
may be this sort of you know highly
personalized wake up about the power of
this that sort of takes privacy out of a
purely theoretical into a practical
realm for a lot and then I'll say one of
the one of the efforts we're making
right now is to drive the point that
echo will be 25 we're actually trying to
specifically reach out to people who are
under the age of 25 I'm sure we have
some in this room anyone or 25 here
handful so we have people who are born
after our electronic communication
privacy law nor we can resonate with the
fact that your world has changed and you
know what's going on to some extent and
these other protections aren't you know
it's really a way to build up because
we're not going to have pictures on
facebook of our teenage drinking years
that you know they may exist in hard
copies we've got yours and they're all
I've done we're actually publishing
research on the very near future so just
wanted to be clear on all of that if we
just got a round of applause for our
great panelists
okay and thank you very much for leading
this wonderful discussions and let's
saying pose him and to speak us off the
whole day for what we heard okay and I
will